I will not give up on
myself I will not give up on my
dreams I will make my life count you're
going to get through this it's who you
are I will make my life
count only two years of high school well
I left to pursue a career in sales C
what is that like steak knives um it was
other kinds of knives too mhm give me a
shot please don't embarrass me hi hi
nice to meet you oh oh pleasure is
mine it's commissions that get you into
Paradise get a doctor to prescribe your
drugs you know when we bill on a full
dose script 40 Grand a year a
month on some level I knew it was
it's a long odds lottery ticket
buried under a thousand rejections and
you got to have the grit and the balls
to reach down and scratch it there's
nothing so inspiring as sheer
desperation you're not not going to make
100k this year it's going to be more
like
[Music]
600 work like your backs against the
wall own your territory own your
territory own a
territory if you don't grow you die
sales are flat sales are flat at 170
million a quar that use your crisis as
your fire you'd be amazed at what you're
capable of
it's not your
fault you're not a bad
person I will not give up on
myself I will not give up on my
dreams I will make my life
count I will make my life
count is it me or is he losing his
hey get the SU SAU get your Sho
[Music]
sauce